nous sommes avec jean marc jancovici
l'inventeur le promoteur de la taxe
carbone en france jean marc jancovici
avant de parler de redistribution
puisque nous allons être taxés c'est un
netbook ou pas oui oui il faut il faut
pas d'impôts il faut pas un nouvel impôt
faut pas avoir peur des mots c'est là où
bien on est contre les impôts par
principe et à ce moment on oublie tout
ce que l'état fait l'enseignement la
médecine au théâtre on oublie ou bien on
n'est pas contre les impôts par principe
qu'à ce moment juste choisir les bons et
ma conviction c'est que c'est un polar
est un très bon impôt et que du reste on
peut très bien se débarrasser de tas
d'autres impôts qui sont pas du tout
intelligent bord alors alors avant de
parler de redistribution françois fillon
nous dit que les grilles cité ne sera
pas concerné le fioul
si j'ai bien compris le gasoil l'essence
et le gaz oui essentiellement alors il y
aurait aussi le charbon si on en
consomme trop beau oui bon donc rochelle
en fait c'est tout ce qui fait du ce2
qui est qui est important c'est que nous
allons payer
oui absolument et quelque chose qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que cette
taxe c'est pas un truc qui va nous
arriver par notre feuille d'impôts 1
oui c'est quelque chose qui va arriver à
travers les augmentations de prix des
énergies qui conduisent à mettre du sel
dans le roster je paierai au bûcher les
acteurs tout simplement
alors pourquoi est ce qu'il ne souhaite
pas mettre l'électricité dedans il ya
deux arguments inquiet bon inquiet
mauvais celui qui est bon c'est de dire
les centrales électriques quand elle
utilise du gaz et du charbon parce que
on a en france à peu près 10 % de notre
électricité qui est produite comme ça
ils sont déjà dans un autre système qui
s'appelle le système européen des permis
négociables ou des quotas humala et ces
gens là ils ont déjà des contraintes qui
leur sont aidés j'ai donc de temps en
temps ils payent déjà ils payent pour
émettre moins donc on dit bon on va pas
leur demander de payer deux fois et à
titre personnel je trouve que c'est pas
idiot donc ils st après il ya le reste
d'électricité celle qui ne fait pas de
co2 et qui en france vient du nucléaire
et des barrages oui ça ça fait à peu
près 90 % de notre électricité
alors là il ya deux attitudes qu'on peut
avoir une première est de dire puisque
savait pas de co2 on parle d'une taxe
carbone donc ils sont pas dans la taxe
carbone c'est l'attitude du gouvernement
il ya une deuxième attitude qu'on peut
avoir qui est de dire si je taxe les
énergies fossiles et pas l'électricité
qui vient du nucléaire et de
l'hydraulique
oui
les énergies fossiles deviennent de plus
en plus cher par exemple je me chauffe
au gaz un moment je dis ça suffit jeunes
chauffés à l'électricité
oui je roule au pétrole ça suffit je
vais rouler à l'électricité enfin encore
faut-il rouler avec three sisters un
certain nombre d'industriels vont dire
bah le gaz ne coûte trop cher je me
prends un four électrique et c'est à ce
moment que se passe-t-il
il ya un risque que le basculement vers
l'électricité aille trop vite pour que
l'appareil productif puisse suivre sans
contrainte ou avec juste des contraintes
gérable je comprends même si on aime
bien le nucléaire on va pas rajouter et
25 centrales nucléaires demain matin il
faut le temps de les construire faut le
temps de les faire frire et surpayés
photos etc
moi j'ai rien contre le nucléaire mais
je suis sûr qu'on va pas en rajouter 15
demain matin donc le l'idée de
d'englober d'électricité c'est de faire
en sorte que dans la majeure partie des
cas de figure faire des économies ça
reste plus intéressant que de changer
d'énergie en passant du gaz ou du fioul
vers l'électricité
c'est ça l'idée dans la proposition de
la fondation nicolas hulot
le premier ministre ne l'entend pas de
cette oreille j'espère qu'ils changent
d'avis pas alors les compensations
quelles sont les informations que vous
avez alors il ya une première
compensations importantes dans cette
affaire c'est qu'on préserve la paix
encore une fois pas oublié je vais
prendre l'exemple de la prime
d'assurance parce que pour moi c'est un
bon exemple c'est quoi une prime
d'assurance
c'est un montant que vous payez
aujourd'hui de manière certaine au
centime près vous sentirez combien vous
allez payer pour vous couvrir contre un
risque qui est pas sûr d'arriver pour
lequel vous avez pas idée de ce que vous
payeriez si vous étiez pas assuré et qui
arrivera plus tard
est ce que si on vous dit que c'est
important de vous assurez vous allez
commencer à dire ça coûte trop cher de
payer la prime donc je vais assurer ma
salle de bain et l'entrée puis j'oublie
la cuisine et la chambre à coucher
oui et non d'accord vous assurer la
totalité de votre logement est là avec
14 euros la tonne monsieur fillon est en
train de dire je vais vous proposer une
prime d'assurance qui vous assurent la
cage d'escalier et la moitié la moitié
de l'appartement ne leur est pas assurée
et en plus c'est un c'est je vais
continuer mon parallèle je vais imaginez
que vous vous assurez contre l' incendie
et que le montant de la prime sert à
mettre les pyromanes en prison eh bien
vous voyez que - vous voulez payer votre
prime d'assurance
plus vous courez le risque d'avoir un
incendie en étant moins bien assurée si
j'apprends en deux ans payé cher si ça
vous arrive alors le principe de la taxe
c'est exactement celui d'art
donc la première des compensations avant
même de parler de savoir où va l'argent
c'est que vous diminuer le nombre de
pyromane et que si jamais ils vous
arrivent des pépins d'accord c'est ça le
premier trajet au concret jean marc
jancovici
oui vous êtes concret c'est d'accord
c'est comme le montant de l'augmentation
des paquets de cigarettes avant même de
se demander où va l'argent
le premier principe c'est d'essayer de
faire en sorte que les gens fument moins
parce qu'on considère que globalement
c'est une bonne affaire
bien sûr il faut moins consommer et le
bénéfice sanitaire alors là c'est le
bénéfice social non mais ça on est on
est presque prêt je me mêle art après
qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'argent il ya
trois manières d'utiliser cet argent
l'entreprise va payer la taxe carbone
alors l'entreprise comment alors ça
c'est ont compensé et tout le monde est
à peu près d'accord ont baissé charges
sociales en baisse et cherchent alors ça
c'est une très bonne affaire pour
l'emploi en france
oui sur le papier parce que quand vous
achetez un dollar ou un euro de pétrole
ou de gaz c'est 100 % des importations
-5 99% parce que on a trois grilles
trolls dans le bassin parisien et le
jugement de bon bref si vous remplacez
sa part un euro dépensé dans n'importe
quoi d'autre il y aura une part d'emploi
français là dedans
j'ai une bonne affaire et si vous
baissez les charges sociales les
entreprises françaises ça sera encore
ainsi donc d'accord
bon d'accord d'accord donc les faits
mais c'est difficile de promettre à une
personne en particulier qu'elle va
retrouver un emploi grâce à ça on est
bien d'accord global englobement
particulier alors pour les entreprises
non pas pour les particuliers il ya deux
manières de faire
la première manière de faire c'est de
dire je prends l'argent à très court
terme je vous rends rien mais je vais
faire des aides ciblées dont par exemple
les gens qui sont à la campagne je vais
les aider à isoler leur logement en
premier parce que c'est plus facile
parce que etc et donc vous allez
peut-être payé votre essence plus cher
mais vous allez payer votre logement
moins cher par le chauffage de votre
logement moins cher et l'un dans l'autre
vous allez à peu près vous avez mais ça
existe déjà il ya des crédits d'impôts
et pas assez d'impôts sont en train de
diminuer
c'est pas pour le moment c'est pas un
truc qui est fait de manière massive
sérieux et c'est que je donne un exemple
je dis pas ce que le gouvernement fait
et bien sûr le principe
ensuite vous pouvez utiliser toujours
cet argent sans rendre directement aux
ménages pour faire des pistes cyclables
par qui il y à vélo des voies de chemin
de fer aider les gens à changer de
métier parce que de façon les joueurs de
la chance oui il ya pas que ça encore
une fois aider les gens à changer de
métier ça va être un truc important 1 le
monde va bouger un etc
et puis vous avez une troisième manière
de faire qui est rendent directement
l'argent au gendre vous prenez l'argent
puis à la fin de l'année vous la faites
un jaillissement c'est compliqué tout ça
oui j'ai une usine à gaz le problème
auquel on s'attaque et carris effet de
serre exotique attaque est compliqué
vous savez maintenir les gens en bonne
santé ça nécessite aussi une usine à gaz
des prélèvements sociaux une sécurité
sociale un système hospitalier tout ça
c'est compliqué et pourtant on trouve
que c'est pas une mauvaise idée
et quand les gens nous envoient le
supérieur est très bonne idée donc le là
c'est exactement pareil ça à calculer ce
que ce que j'emmènerai on va pas rendre
aux gens l'argent qu'ils ont dépensé ce
qu'on fait c'est que on prend la
totalité de l'argent perçu fait un
chèque du même montant pour tout le
monde est d'accord
en enlevant les gens comme vous et moi
intérêts en nommant les gens comme vous
et moi parce qu'on gagne trop d'argent
pour qu'on ne vende quelque chose oui
donc on va en l'idée de la commission
rocard c'est de dire on prend et on rend
aux 10 20 30 40 50% des français pour le
dial exactement qui gagnent le moins et
ça ça alors quel intérêt
l'intérêt c'est que vous êtes toujours
très sensible même si on vous rend
l'argent à la fin de l'année aux
variations de prix que vous voyez
souvent c'est pas à vous que je vais
apprendre que quand le prix de la
baguette où le prix du ticket de métro
bouge souvent ça fait plus de
remue-ménage que quand le prix des
loyers et bouge alors que les dépenses
des français pour le logement s'est
considérablement supérieur à ce qu'ils
dépensent ticket de métro ou en pin ou
envie de même en ligne d'essence les
dépenses des loyers c'est supérieur aux
dépenses d'essence en attendant le prix
de l'essence est un sujet plus sensible
que le montant des loyers dans dans le
relèvement d'opinion
parce que c'est un truc que vous payez
souvent oui ce qui est important c'est
de monter le prix du truc que vous payez
souvent oui même si on vous fait un
chèque à la fin de l'année oui comme ça
vous allez commencer à réfléchir à ce
que vous dépensez ça va vous rendre ça
va rendre économiquement compétitif des
tas de solutions alternatives donc par
exemple pour votre voiture vous allez
vous acheter une voiture plus petite ce
qui vous fera pas
extrêmement mal voilà les industriels
sauront que vous avez envie de vous
acheter une voiture plus petite donc ils
vont commencer en faire comme ils ont
fait entre 2000 et 2008 pour d'autres
raisons
on a vu apparaître sur le marché des tas
de petites voitures qui se vendent très
bien puis à des tas de gens quand noms
qui sont très contents donc le là il va
se passer exactement la même chose
et le fait de rendre l'argent à la fin
de l'année fait que l'on va vous on va
aider justement les gens à financer la
transition s'est par exemple barrier
pourra vous dire puisqu'on vous donne un
chèque à la fin de l'année moi je vais
vous aider à financer tel truc qui vous
permet de consommer moins d'énergie bon
alors écoutez on va demander à matthieu
vrilliard quelles sont les premières
questions et vous allez venir avec nous
sur rmc jean marc jancovici pour
répondre à d'autres questions après les
informations de 9h avec les accus
belliard questions des auditeurs de rmc
les toutes premières questions celle de
véronique qui est à paris on parle de 3
ou 4 centimes par litre d'essence pour
2010 quelle va être l'évolution combien
2011 2015 et 2030 par exemple voilà
est-ce qu'il faut qu'elle soit il faut
que ça augmente cette taxe carbone bâtir
le sait c'est un des éléments absolument
fondamentaux en fait il faut bien
comprendre que ce qui va se passer au
fil des ans et que les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre doivent baisser et de
toute façon la quantité de pétrole
disponible un jour ou l'autre va se
mettre à baisser aussi donc pour
anticiper ce genre de mouvement il faut
pas qu'on vous dise on vous dit ce qui
se passe cette année puis après on vous
dit plus rien c'est un peu comme si vous
voulez empêcher quelqu'un de fumer vous
lui dites l'année prochaine des
cigarettes vont coûter très cher puis
l'année d'après je sais pas combien il
coûte se bouge c'est pas vrai d'accord
vous faites pas de plan ce genre de
contexte
donc il faut que ça augmente alors de
combien l'ordre de grandeur de ce que
proposait la commission rocard c'était
quelques euros de plus par année à la
tonne de co2 ce qui en pratique
représente de l'ordre d'un centime par
litre sur les carburants routiers et par
année mais c'est sur 20 ou 30 ans oui
d'accord donc une fois qu'on est engagé
dans le mouvement vous savez que tous
les ans ça va vous coûter un peu plus
cher
d'accord mais pas de manière
insupportable bon autre question mathieu
celle d'albert dans le vaucluse monsieur
jancovici est ce que vous êtes déçu du
montant de la taxe carbone surtout
justement est-ce qu'elle sera efficace
si elle est faible et ce qu'il faut pas
taper très fort très vite alors tapé
très fort très vite ça serait
insupportable si vous si vous dites à
quelqu'un qu'il a le cancer et vous
allez l'en débarrasser en l'assommant à
coups de marteau
je pense qu'il va très bien marché
puisque une fois que des morts il ya
plus de cancers il va quand même être
contre donc le et il aura raison donc le
de démarrer à des montants exorbitants
et pas souhaitable le montant que
proposait la commission rocard c'est à
dire 32 euros la tonne de co2 bon ça
représentait 6 à 7 centimes
d'augmentation par litre la première
année oui et après c'était de l'ordre du
centime en plus tous les ans oui c'est
on peut pas discutable c'est pas ça que
cette année par ailleurs je pense que ni
je pense pas que monsieur rocard soit
connue pour avoir voulu
de tout temps le malheur du peuple de
terreur pourquoi est ce que je suis déçu
à 14 oui oui absolument je suis allé sur
quoi selon vous 14
allez je vais lâcher les gros mots parce
que je pense que monsieur fillon n'a pas
les idées claires sur alors d'abord il
est partiellement en service commandé et
ensuite je pense qu'il n'a pas les idées
claires sur les dangers qui nous
guettent
donc il est comme ce que je disais tout
à l'heure dans la position du médecin
qui se demandent qui se dit peut-être
que vous avez le cancer peut-être que
vous avez pas alors dans le doute je
vais vous donner un cachet d'aspirine ça
complètement rien c'est ridicule et je
suis pas le seul à être déçu quand vous
demandez aux gens avec qui on a un peu
batailler comme par exemple ufc que
choisir
ils sont aujourd'hui sur une position
que je trouve normal qui est de dire un
système coercitif mais dont on comprend
clairement la finalité et qui est
clairement au service des français
finalement on est pour oui sauf que si
c'est pour faire un truc tiède à l'eau
de rose là à 14 euros la tonne et puis
après on sait pas où on va et c'est là
on est contre et la raison est bien
merci jean marc jancovici je vous garde
sur rmc vous allez venir après les infos
de 9h répondre à toutes les questions
d'auditeurs elles sont nombreuses
merci à vous il est 8 heures 58 merci